hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the grand chest towards your
next move blitz tournament in Leuven
it's Hikaru Nakamura versus Wesley so
now this game is this game is quite
outstanding and it's really amazing that
Hikaru Nakamura used the this opening
trick trick already three times in this
tournament and not only in this
tournament he used that three times in
one day so in in the course of I believe
eight rounds he used it three times to
defeat three 2800 players well 28 or or
so so and it's a very interesting this
game also features a spectacular Queen
sacrifice that actually never took place
on the board because it's a blitz game
and one of the players unfortunately
missed it but that's why we analyzed
chess games before we check out this
game we do have a nice photo challenge
so best of luck to everyone I'm not
gonna give away any hints as I believe
it's a it's a pretty easy one you know I
shouldn't really have any problems with
this one so here it is best of luck to
everyone
I believe this photo was taken at the
time he became an international master
and at the time he was the youngest
international master in the world so
there you have it and before we check
out the game we have a very nice photo
of Gary Kasparov taken by David Lara so
let's just enjoy it for a couple of
seconds okay there it is and you see he
has a nice grand chest to her jacket
very nice okay let's check out this game
we have Knight to f3 Knight to f6 let me
just fix that b3 g6 Bishop b2 and Bishop
to g7 so directly opening the names of
Larson variation and it's very
interesting this a Hikaru uses this for
the third time and we're actually gonna
see two games in this video because well
you'll see what I mean III we have
castles d 4 D 5 D captures on c5 and now
Queen to a5 check c3 and this is the
position that was on the board in the
game Hikaru Nakamura versus onigiri then
Nakamura had this exact same position
against Sharma micariff and
for the third time he has this position
on the board against Wesley so Wesley
continues the same way as mama Derrick
did with Queen captures on c5 but it's
very interesting as it's very short
we're gonna show Nakamura versus onigiri
Gary went rook to e8 then came before we
have Queen to c7 and c4 now a5 a3
captures captures captures captures this
is all pretty much irrelevant Knight
attacks pawn we have a Bishop to e5
attacking queen pawn defense captures
captures and Bishop to c3 defending the
pawn Knight h5 forcing a trade of
bishops captures captures b5 attacking
the knight Queen to a5 check night
blocks and now Knight to c5 preparing
Knights the b3 now we have Bishop to e2
and now comes knife to e4 pinning that
well attacking the print piece we have
castles and now nice to see three
attacking the Queen and also the
undefended Bishop well if the Queen
moves it will be undefended Queen e1 and
now Gary blunders nice to East six and
now a her Nakamura really takes a nice
advantage of this he plays nice to e4
now attacking Geary spin piece and of
course if you capture you lose the Queen
the Queen is undefended and a5 your only
choices and Knight captures I need to
wit check so Queen captures e2 now comes
Rock to f8 but this was never played it
was actually after Queen to e2 that an
if you resign the game why did he resign
there's really no defense against Knight
to f6 check winning the exchange
whatever you play the threat of Knight
to f6 followed by Queen to d2 Queen to
be two is too strong
so here give a resigned as really
there's nothing to do is simply check is
coming and whatever you play Queen d2 is
coming and there is no defense white
will win the exchange and the game so a
very interesting game that was but here
against ma media of played the Queen
captures and c5 against Nakamura and so
does Wesley so Queen captures on c5 and
here comes the bishop to a3 again
tricking both of them as this completely
loses the East 7th pawn there's no way
to defend this pawn queen this is 7 and
Alberto captures any 7 so it's a clean
pawn and well it's basically a
you're now up up upon and it's up to you
whether you will convert this or not
Ruki ate butter up captors on f6 Bishop
captures on f6 and now Knight the d4
interestingly in the game against my
media of nakamura went Bishop to e2 so
it's like he already checked this you
know with the engine that maybe Knight
d4 was was better than Bishop to e2 but
who knows 96
now the scam Bishop to e2 d5 we have
castles knife to e5 Queen to d2 and now
Bishop to d7 92 83 rope to c8 rook a to
c1 and now a six rook F to D one Queen
to a5 attacking the knight Queen B 2
defending and now rook to c7 C 4 and C 4
seems like a very nice move he wants to
get rid of his weak pawn and then really
he wants to enjoy his extra pawn but
this allows this Bishop to e7 idea
piling up and under knight on a 3 here
nakamura plays Knight d2 c 2 opens up a
discovered attack on the night but here
Wesley simply repeats Bishop to f6
threatening Knight f3 check and winning
the Queen so he car repeats back knife
to d4 and Wesley sleep with simple
repeats Bishop to e7 again with the
attack here and here if he Caro plays
Knight back then it's pretty much gonna
be a draw a repetition as Wesley would
really enjoy a draw which would most
likely win him win him this tournament
as it's very you know maybe maybe
kurakin and MV elf warrior pursuing him
win their games but it's still unclear
whether that would help them overtake
Wesley but Nakamura isn't interested
nice to be one he wants to keep this
game on rook a to c8 and now simply seek
after son b5 going for series of
exchanges
rook captures rook captures rook
captures Queen captures and now Queen
kept resonate to Queen captures and d5
was also possible but Wesley figures
that it's better to [ __ ] the Queen
side and deal with the other the other
pawn later now he has two to one an
advantage on the Queen side maybe he can
create something out of this Knight to
c3 attacking the Queen Queen F
and pound h3 Bishop to eight we have
King - h1 and now King to g7f for
attacking the knight and now comes the
Knight to d7 was the move
probably that should have been played
but here sorry wrong Bishop Bishop -
before that would a double attack on the
night and here hikaru does take his time
to figure things out and this was pretty
much the only blitz game that he car was
in time trouble but he finds the the
best move Knight the d1 we have nice to
d7 getting nice out of the attack and
here nakamura mrs. Queen c8 a very nice
move attacking the bishop and the b7
pawn after we block this Queen captures
and then after Knight captures here
Bishop to c4 keeping the extra pawn but
with a much better position for white
but okay after 97 efore simply creating
a massive point century pawn Center and
it will be very hard to play against
this Bishop to d2 attacking the Queen
and the f4 point but nakamura takes care
of this simply queen to be 2 now of
course Bishop captures an f4 isn't
possible because knight of 5 wins the
game immediately with into g7 checkmate
so after Queen B - Knight to f6 and now
g3 simply protecting the f4 pawn and E
for pawn is again not possible as Knight
to f5 would win the game once again
so King g8 and now Bishop to f3 and
defending the pawn Bishop to d7 we had
King to g2 at defending the h3 pawn
brush up to b4 and now comes Knight to
e2 a very nice idea as now the knight on
f6 is undefended so Queen captures is a
threat you have to do something about
this 98 is a very ugly looking move but
it's a move you have to play Knight to
h5 also possible but Wesley plays Bishop
to e7 and this allows nakamora d6 and he
plays it immediately so of course you
cannot capture the pawn as Queen would
capture on f6 Bishop to DA and now Queen
to c3 offering a trade of Queens now you
could trade winds but then if 5 is
coming and you don't want to play play
boots against the car in this position
with Queens of the board so Queen a - we
have Queen B - again offering
trait queen a5 and night - III worship
c6 we have E 5 Knight to d5 and now
Knight captures on d5 but sure character
Sundy 5 Queen to c3 again offering a
trait of Queens Queen to a2 threatening
this very annoying Queen captures an e2
as the bishop would be pinned King to f1
defending wouldn't be one check and here
hikaru played King to g2 but the arbiter
stopped the game here because Hikaru
played a move with one hand and then he
pressed the clock with the other hand
now I I know that this rule existed but
I didn't I thought that they gave up on
this rule I thought that now you can
actually you know play move and then hit
it with your other hand
as you know the rules are changing all
the time and he he stopped the game here
he explained it to the players and you
know it really he car was really really
going for the kill here and it really
kind of killed his mojo so and yeah we
do have even a photo this is this is the
arbiter look cornet so look at it look
at him imagine that you're playing a
game that you know either either you
will win $40,000 or you will not and
then this guy comes and stops your game
you know and then you have to keep on
playing the game very very tough stuff
you know so yeah King g2 was played and
here Queen to d1 again threatening Queen
captures an e2 we have night cap night
to d4 and now Bishop to b6 attacking the
night Bishop captures and d5 gossip
capture sandy for attacking the Queen
Queen to c4 and here it seems that
Wesley was also pretty intimidated by
the arbiter Luke Kornet as he misses a
great opportunity here here Wesley
played h5 but it's very unfortunate for
him because here he has a beautiful
series of moves that well with the best
defense result in black winning the game
via a beautiful checkmate so I tried to
pause the video here and figure out this
very nice series of moves I will give it
a couple seconds as usual so for those
of you who found it congratulations you
just might have you know created the
next
American Beauty and for those who just
want to enjoy the show the move
Wesley played missed with Queen to g1
check seems obvious I mean even if you
don't find anything why not play Queen
g1 check but okay the idea is of course
after King f3 you can simply play Queen
III check and now if you move back then
this leads the checkmate but okay of
course you're not gonna play this after
Queen III checked you're gonna run away
King to g4 and now you'll find h5 way to
check King to h4 and now King to g7 of
course such a move is hard to consider
in a blitz game where you're very low on
time you have to first give up the f7
pawn and after Queen capture Bishop
captures on f7 and now comes King to h6
and after Queen to e6 simply threatening
to capture here with checkmate the game
is over because Queen captures on f4
with check comes and now whatever white
plays a white has a variety of options
they all lead to checkmate
of course accepting the Queen sacrifice
results in the shop - f2 this will be
checkmate
you can even block this with the Queen
then g5 will be checkmate now you cannot
capture of course the pawn because the
Queen is pinned and of course if you
block it with g4 then again Queen to f2
or once again but you have to will be
checkmate so a beautiful beautiful idea
but unfortunately was missed by Wesley
he did not play Queen to g1 or Queen to
d2 was also winning rather he played h5
immediately probably preparing this you
know so the King cannot escape here but
this allows h4 now creating a flight
Square for his king we have Queen g1
check and now King to h3 by Nakamura
Bishop here threatening to checkmate
Nakamura on g3 but now measure of the
g-tube we have Queen to d1 and now Queen
the CIT check we have came here and now
Queen the c3
King goes here of course the threat was
a sex with check we have Queen offering
a queen trade here and as Hikaru is is
up a pawn Wesley doesn't want to trade
we have Queen to d4 and now Queen
captures on b7 Nakamura grabs another
Pole
queen d3 queen to f3 now comes Queen to
f5 check King moves and Bishop to c5
Queen to c3 attacking the bishop bishop
moves back and now Queen to d2 again
attacking the bishop bishop to be 6 and
now d7 so a couple of moves plays you
know to position the Queen I by
attacking the bishop and now d6 has been
played of course you have to block this
Bishop to d8 Queen to d6 and now there
is very little black can do there's no
way to harass the White King and simply
Queens e6 win c8 is coming so a5 we have
Queen to c6 geez clean g7 now comes
Queen to see it and here there is
nothing you can do there is no no way
for Queen to actually protect the bishop
I removed the bishop was just gonna
promote the Queen which is what Wesley
did he plays queen cap better captures
maybe hoping that he Cara will capture
it but he gouges brought another Queen
into the game and you will either
capture and then you're down a piece or
whatever you play we initiate will be
checkmate so yeah a very interesting
game and let's just check the standings
after this game so sorry not that these
are the standings after 18 rounds of
blitz so 2 days of bits have been played
and Wesley so keeps his lead after the
rapid section and it's very interesting
magazine for Sheila Graham and Sergey
kurakin they both had 21 and a half
points before the game and the West I
saw had 22 games
22 points before the final round but all
three of them lost in the final round so
Wesley kurakin and Maxime basho de
Graaff all three of them lost and you
know Wesley keeps his lead and wins wins
the the the rapid and blitz tournament
in Leuven and Hikaru Nakamura with his
amazing streak in the last day climbs up
to 4th place and even 4th place is very
important here because you do get some I
don't know how much money you get but I
don't think money is all that important
to he Caro after all he's on a Red Bulls
payroll but it's very important because
4 places get qualified to the London
tournament so yeah Wesley wins I believe
37 and a half thousand dollars and first
place here so last year he almost wanted
but Magnus Carlsen crushed the field in
the Blitz section so did this this year
Wesley does it so yeah yeah we just
mentioned three of them but we never
mentioned all of them yet there's he
covered in our onion in fifth place
Grisha quit in sixth mommy tiara in
second
Anandi in eighth and then Fabiano
Caruana who who had really a terrible
rapid experience in the terrible Blitz
experience but even worse than that
onigiri who is a wild card in this
tournament and it's you know it's always
difficult when you know you have a bad
few days and then it seems like you know
you're something is wrong with you but
you know someone has if someone wins
someone has to lose and if you remember
the Tata Steel chess tournament onigiri
really crushed the field along with
alongside Carlsen but then he was the
Magnus Cross and in the in the tiebreaks
in the playoffs so yeah yeah basically
that's the game and that that will end
my coverage of the 2008 in your next
moves rapid and let's turn them into
Louvre and I do hope you enjoyed it
this will be the last video I'm posting
today so you know hope you enjoyed this
game and the entire coverage of this
tournament then before some tournament
starts so we're gonna continue with our
on on vs. constant series and their 2013
World Chess Championship match so as
usual you can check out to my previous
videos here think all for watching and I
will see you soon with hopefully another
interesting video from the Coulson
undone series so yeah I'm gonna go enjoy
the festival and you know it's my
birthday today so we're gonna enjoy that
as well thank you all and see you soon